foreign  [Music]  [Applause]  one question what's going on with the  gloves  oh my God you're engaged when did this  happen it was last night you know what  that means Bachelorette the book says  that we can't reject our destiny and I  think we should all go to Italy Italy we  might never have a chance to do  something like this again  [Music]  I love this city I love anything that's  falling apart more than I am  life is unpredictable  and it's the surprises that make it  worth living  says if you would like you should see  I'm sorry C is Cucina it means kitchen I  bet it's fig just don't do anything I  would do that's actually really good  advice  [Music]  wait a minute a buff cop just happens to  drive by okay show me your concealed  weapon  I do think he missed his calling  [Music]